let us start to talk about million
transforms and integration about new
opportunities to make jump in these
directions Mellin transform just a
period recently and it is basically
Fourier transform but with some kind
modifications and below we will see
about this modern multiply million
transform was implemented at last by my
former PhD student Victor Adamczyk who
became consultant consultant for a while
but about 20 years ago I am working 25
years in company we finished integrate
and it was small team mostly Russians
Ali Ahmed chef Victor Adamczyk Alexei
bocharov
and also the beginning Kelly Roach who
made C code but at that time we did not
implement milling transform by some
reasons but we made major G function at
that time which includes many many
particular cases practically all the
most usable functions which exist at the
world elementary and special functions
are the cases of Mayer G function and
currently after 20 years
from that time we started to rebuild all
features connected with integrate and
started from Marin transform you see
table examples and you see also that we
have inverse Mellin transform which
defined by corresponding formulas know
about gamma it's special conversation
which appeared in this integral I omit
it right now and again you see that
inverse Mellin transform works
effectively even the integrand we have
gamma functions in this example two
gammas and result is basal function but
if we have not two but many gamma
functions such constructions is called
Mayer G function no million transform
and satisfy convolution property and
here you see how it works
[Music]
million convolve appeared and product of
basal function convolution of basal
function relates by this rule and we
have many properties show please
relations which connect Fourier
transform and parent transform first
relation shows second relation shows
that Marin transform is a modification
of Fourier transform if we change
functions and variable and the same we
can say about convolution its last
relations Laplace transform also
connected with Mellin transform but the
most important property here is a
possible relation which allows to relate
integrals from
F multiplied on J in this seat or in
situations when image of each function
miron transform of each function is
gamma functions it means we will have
found the integrand product of gamma
functions for example first function has
5 gamma functions second function CSS 10
gamma Farson together 15 maybe
and so our problem how to leads is
integral by vertical line gamma minus
infinity and so on and this problem is
called the representation major
functions through hyper geometric and
other functions go down please
so no major function you see definition
of this we have a magnetic you sets of
gamma functions and if we have just M
equal 1 and P Q absent no we have only
one gamma fashion in this situation we
have exponential function and right now
we have comment which allow to convert
usual functions to Mayer G form it is
called mere Jarrod use it means that we
can can transform all functions of hyper
geometric type in one language in one
notation if we I can tell joke that 10th
from 100 functions which humans as
civilization to which human civilization
gave names we can put on garbage instead
of this 100 names like logarithmic
exponential basis and so on and so on
we can use only one name mil G B G with
concrete parameters and below you can
see table cases this K table works right
now in company in wolfram mathematica
and cosine integral goes to mir g form
and so on and so on
together 3000 plus cases yes and go more
this huge table allow us to forget about
other functions which stay left in
website of this table and work only with
mayor g and for this mayor G we have
corresponding formulas and it will allow
us to who put these formulas in
integration procedure and computer will
have only one job to substitute concrete
parameters in this super complicated
generic formulas and this is level which
we want to realize right now but before
we realized a different approach
it was Victor's program we demanded from
computer to overly it may Toto to think
too late too much it means we had
problems box and so on because
evaluation goes by exotic always
sometimes in right now it will be
straight way and right now we can even
demonstrate later on how fast it can be
no 1 second 10 integrals something like
this yes and let's go more next page
close this
Ruby
no no return bet is if possible a page
for maybe oh you open this no page for
ya okay
so no letter let me stop about integrate
but I hope that we can realize this
during nearest months and maybe one two
year and also we started a big job to
rebuilt indefinite integrate I started
this from comparison using Ruby
can we look and Ruby yeah
Ruby testing collection it's a
fifty-five thousand indefinite integrals
which was used to develop Ruby system
Ruby it is rule-based integration it was
done presented for free on internet by
Albert rich who lives in Hawaii and here
you see comparison this with maple with
Mathematica and Mathematica on second
position we will eat five fifty five
thousand noon something like eighty two
percentage done but nano we 90
percentage but not all effectively more
compact can be used what we can do in
this area for indefinite integration at
first indefinite integration it is part
of definite because if we take integral
from product of two major functions
we can take one male ji unit step
function instead one male G and we will
get indefinite integral and so this
approach allowed Olli it right now
for example three thousand indefinite
integrals which Ruby cannot do mostly
and no we have formulas like integral
from polynomial in degree alpha and if
polynomial is has no degree three for
example such formula gives I believe one
function and in any case I have set of
very generic and super generic formulas
for this area and after implementation
we again can put instead hundreds
formulas several tens formulas and
integration will substitute concrete
parameter inside of these formulas and
much more than McDonald he developed
special technology which allows to match
situations like X in degree alpha when
alpha is zero it means you know this guy
is absent no X integral zero one no and
if we have such factor it is absent
factor and but this can be inside of big
formulas and so we can catch using one
formula we can catch many many
particular cases he will talk about this
and we have timed here keep going okay
this is a you see how version 10 was
compared right now I worked with big
action about seventy thousand formulas
which include Ruby and here you see
distribution and we still have problems
with five thousand almost six thousand
integrals and I started to solve these
problems to cover this by special super
generic formulas and so you know I think
that our system can be on top existing
integrate system if evolution will not
be done on this first level we can go to
what we have right now is for definite
end for indefinite integrals yes and
also I can say that it all this opened
all this I keep in mind opportunity to
convert functions into marriage reform
and this algorithm which I mentioned
about zero mention yes and many others
allows to reboot no many since it's also
take effect for summation we can do
inside style summation sums we can this
use pattern mention in the dissolve also
super complicated differential equation
and then catch particular cases
different level many applications yes
only with on half is main power not so I
need in people or near me not only then
but other who can assist in this super
huge job because many many directions
yeah and we have time 10 means
yes let's so I can say something about
the direction about symbolic
differentiation a symbolic and
fractional differentiation version 11.10
Alok differentiation or the n positive
integer N and they were under
implemented this soon you will see I
think in this year before new year yeah
and also we have huge collection
derivatives for five hundred functions
I build special grid for demonstration
let's show down down yes cases this one
for example we can go go we can see here
function x alpha degree alpha first
derivative and then derivative or the N
next line this is again the same
function and integral of order no
indefinite integral from this it means
derivative or the minus one and then no
fractional derivative of this guy and
this is small fragment and I made this
job for about five hundred functions and
it will fractional differentiation from
this job will be part of in new
integrate and I think will have own name
fractional there because it will have
options and so on and so on
fractional differentiation it's not
symbolic differentiation is a little
different and
about thirty years ago we published the
big mammography bout to 100 1000 pages
some co Cuba's marichoube integrals and
derivatives of rational order about this
subject ya know we have I finished this
talk and I will give time to then thanks
um this is close enough I can it's not a
big room just yell okay so Oleg was
talking about for kind of giving a
backstop to integrate and and some of
the other functions using these really
general formulas and so one thing we
needed to to do before that would work
is to write a little code to enhance our
pattern matching capabilities so if we
well this is supposed to be a surprise
there we go
so if we say I have some formula the
left side includes something like Co sub
X to the alpha sine of X to the beta
Mathematica can already recognize
instances of this pattern if our
parameters alpha and beta are nonzero so
a little bit of syntax you might not
know is if you if you actually want to
catch the cases where these exponents
are one you put a little period after
the underscore
but anyway so say we make this
definition for this pattern we want you
know some operator you know in our case
integrate two to evaluate to some
some function and so here we've got two
for alpha and yeah we don't beta doesn't
show up but it's implicitly one
Mathematica is already able to recognize
this but however if we have something
like cosine of Y squared since this beta
here went to 0 this sine of X goes away
but this is we can't handle this at this
moment this is actually a much much more
difficult problem so the easiest
solution would be to just create a
function that defines down values for
all possibilities of the parameters
equaling zero so this you can actually
do with just a little bit of code and
let's so then say we've got so far input
we've got our so our operator I guess I
should rename this there you step so
we'll just call this operator right so
if we input say our left side hands who
went up you know opie of this input to
equal this output and in terms of
integrate we want to make sure that our
parameters are free of our variable of
integration X so if we go ahead and
shift enter we can see we get all the
possible down values so I've eliminated
so here we've got a since if C equals
zero then this kind of takes care of the
case when you know a equals zero B
equals zero so I've eliminated the
redundant cases but you
if our expression is not you know is not
nested like this there aren't as many
redundant cases and you know we have a
number of down values exponential and
our number of these free parameters so
this is an exactly scalable solution but
it works for small small instances so
then if we say apply this operator to
sign of 2y y we get this our function H
out on so that in this cave one cave to
or just these are arbitrary constants
okay so then let's actually apply this
to a real example so now this is one of
Oleg's formulas I I took and we get you
know again some very general formula so
yet you know the more general the
formula the more the more down values
you get and then we can apply this so
this was this is our toy integration
function int so let's let's define some
test function and see what it does to
that so here we you know for some very
complicated integrand you know by
applying this formula we get you know
some output using that apple f1 function
and then we can check that this is
correct by plugging in some random
values for our our free parameters and
and x and luckily we get the same output
for the original function versus
differentiating the integrated function
we can try again keeps working ok but
this is not a not a scalable solution
what I'm working on
now is instead of storing all these down
values just looking at the parse trees
and trying to match the parse trees of
our instance versus the parse tree of
the left-hand side of our formula yeah
so supposed to say thank you on this
page but I guess it doesn't but thank
you
[Applause]